ligne à présent avec le général vincent
desportes bonjour merci d'être avec nous
d'après l'armée ukrainienne l'offensive
russe a ralenti comment peut-on analyser
cette relative accalmie sur le terrain
d'après vous est ce que c'est le calme
avant avant la tempête il ya plusieurs
éléments dans cette affaire-là la
première d'évidence et que le plan
initial de monsieur poutine n'a pas
fonctionné je pense que les plans était
de prendre kiev vers vendredi midi et
donc on est déjà à trois jours de retard
ça c'est la première chose et
effectivement il est évident que
monsieur poutine erreur d'interprétation
ne s'attendait pas à une résistance
aussi forte donc le plan n'a pas
fonctionné ça c'est le 1 le 2 c'est
qu'on ne peut pas imaginer une offensive
se déroulant sans sang moment où est
obligé de s'arrêter nous sommes les
russes ont une armée blindée avec des
chars des véhicules transport de troupes
cela exige à la fois
des tonnes de carburant et des tonnes et
des tonnes de munitions donc plus je
m'enfonçais son territoire ukrainien
plus je suis obligé de d'avoir des
norias de véhicules de transport qui
sont longs et c'est donc le rythme d'une
guerre mécanisée elle est toujours comme
ça j'attaque je m'arrête je recapitalise
j'attaque je m'arrête je recapitalise
donc à plusieurs phénomènes qui joue le
premier le plus important étant quand
même l'incroyable la remarquable
résistance du peuple kenyan
général vincent desportes hier c'est
cette guerre en ukraine a pris un autre
tournant avec cette menace de vladimir
poutine d'utiliser les forces nucléaires
personne n'est dans la tête du chef du
kremlin bien sûr mais peut-on craint que
le conflit prenne cette dangereuse
direction alors en tout cas on n'a pas
le droit de ne pas le prends comme une
hypothèse sérieuse c'est une hypothèse
sérieuse on joue on ne joue plus là avec
quelques centaines de milliers nord où
quelques villes détruites on parle avec
la destruction de grands ville et in
fine et sur mon aux extrêmes à la halle
avec destruction du monde donc il faut
et c'est ça le raisonnement stratégique
je dois faire comme si monsieur poutine
allait utiliser ses d'armes nucléaires
ou avait dans la tête de le faire et
donc c'est par rapport à 7 c'est cette
donnée là que je dois prendre dans mon
raisonnement stratégique et ne pas dire
c'est disproportionné c'est pas
raisonnable et c'est oui c'est ça n'est
pas encore ce qu'est et ce n'est pas
raisonnable mais cela a été dit par
quelqu'un qui peut lancer dans quelques
dizaines de minutes six mille têtes
nucléaires dans le monde alors il est
clair que ce n'est pas les l'hypothèse
la plus probable mais elle pourrait le
devenir si on ne la prend pas en compte
le dialogue stratégique c'est bien ça je
dois considérer que l'autre est capable
du pire et donc on est rentré dans un
espèce de deux avatars d'une espèce de
deux bras de fer entre monsieur poutine
est évidemment le l'occident je dirais
la réponse à ce qu'a dit monsieur
poutine pour l'instant elle a été faire
mal et c'est bien c'est la décision de
l'europe de d'envoyer d'envoyer des
armes défensives heures à l'étal avec
des avions donc on voit bien qu'on est
dans cette affaire-là mais on ne doit
pas oublier que la porte du feu
nucléaire est ouverte génialement
général vincent desportes des
pourparlers un doivent se tenir
aujourd'hui à la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la biélorussie
restez avec nous on va tout de suite
écouter le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky qui s'est exprimé au sujet de
ces pourparlers puis on en parle tout de
suite après bien
je vous le dis franchement 12 comme
d'habitude je ne crois pas vraiment en
résultat de cette rencontre
mais il faut tout essayer
pour qu'aucun ukrainien et le moindre
doute que j'ai tout tenté en tant que
président afin de mettre fin à la guerre
quand une opportunité à une même
minuscule s'est présentée serge takenne
chance
on l'a bien compris il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'espoir côté ukrainien suite à
ces pour parler que peut-on en attendre
de ces discussions d'après vous général
desportes ce qu'on peut en attendre
d'abord c'est qu'ils existent ce qui est
évidemment fondamental on sort de la
guerre soit par la destruction totale
soit par un compromis à un moment donné
qui aura été atteint justement par le
dialogue donc il est extrêmement
important qu'un dialogue soit établi et
qu'ils ne cessent pas pendant toutes les
guerres ont terminé comme ça si on te
rappelle la guerre du vietnam les
conversations de paris ont duré plus
d'un an et pendant tout ce temps la
guerre a continué l'important c'est de
pouvoir se parler à partir du moment où
on ne se parle plus alors la montée aux
extrêmes et devient devient probable
donc déjà ce qu'on attend c'est qu'ils
existent ensuite ils vont évoluer il n'y
a rien à en attendre des médias comme
des sanctions économiques d'ailleurs qui
ne produiront rien dans l'immédiat mais
c'est tout un ensemble de choses qui va
finir par produire ce qui est
fondamental c'est de maintenir le canaux
de dialogue de communication ouvert
c'est parce que tant khrouchtchev que
kennedy ont réussi à maintenir ce canaux
ouverts pendant la crise terrible des
treize jours qui est là il ya 60 ans la
crise de cuba un qui est la précédente
crise nucléaire qui aurait pu détruire
le monde c'est bien parce qu'ils ont
réussi à maintenir ce dialogue qui sont
arrivés finalement à négocier une sortie
de crise par le haut et c'est bien ce
qu'il faut faire on ne sort d'une crise
que c'est finalement chacun le sentiment
de pas tout perdre et d'être un peu
gagnants de la sortie de crise j'ai
envie de vous interroger sur un point
particulier certaines fonctionnalités de
google maps ont été désactivés en
ukraine c'était des outils qu'ils
pouvaient être utilisés pour suivre le
mouvement des troupes notamment selon
vous est ce que c'est une bonne décision
d'avoir supprimé ces outils pour pour
l'ukraine en ces temps de guerre
écoutez il ya deux choses il ya deux
nécessités là qu'ils sont en train de se
confronter la première source on voit
bien que l'ukraine ne joue pas mais
enfin il ya une émotion très forte en
occident par rapport à cette guerre-là
cette émotion elle suppose qu'ils aient
une communication qui est qui et des
images bon d'un côté donc il faut qu'ils
les canaux qu'il soit ouvert d'un autre
côté il est évident que la guerre repose
d'abord sur sur le surprit sur la
surprise sur le secret est donc si les
russes pouvaient que connaîtra la vence
parfaitement les déplacements des
troupes d'ukrainiens et ses troupes
russes devraient un avantage
considérable donc on voit bien accueilli
ben il faut jouer entre ces deux
nécessités moi la première nécessité
quand même parce qu'il s'agit de
d'arrêter les forces bruce c'est
évidemment de faire en sorte que les
russes en sable moins possible sur les
mouvements troupe ukrainien restez avec
nous